i'm joined by dr jenny harris the chief
executive of the uk health security
agency and by professor steve paris the
medical director of nhs england
we've always known that the winter
months would pose the greatest threat to
our road to recovery
the darker skies the colder weather
provide perfect conditions
not just for coveted 19 to thrive but
for other seasonal viruses too like flu
and norovirus
ahead of winter just as we expected
we're starting to see this impact
cases are rising
and yesterday we reported 43
738 new cases across the uk
up 16 percent from the previous week
and they could go yet as high as a
hundred thousand a day
we're also seeing greater pressure on
the nhs
across the uk we're now approaching 1
000 hospitalizations per day
the nhs is performing with distinction
and i'd like to thank everyone who's
working so hard to keep us
safe and we'll do what it takes
to make sure that this pressure doesn't
become unsustainable and that we don't
allow the nhs to become overwhelmed
deaths remain mercifully low but they
are still sadly over 100 a day
this pandemic is not over
thanks to the vaccination program
yes the the link between cases
and hospitalizations and deaths
has significantly weakened
but it's not broken
so we must all remember
that this virus will be with us for the
long term and that it remains a threat
a threat to our loved ones
and a threat to the progress that we've
made in getting our nation closer to
normal life
we're looking closely at the data
and we won't be implementing our plan b
of contingency measures at this point
but we'll be staying vigilant preparing
for all eventualities while
strengthening our vital defenses that
can help us fight back against this
virus